the jurgen experience i'd say you're
honest and i mean this i think you're
one of the
most open-minded people i've ever met
thank you you have very little like
[ __ ] off in you i got a little [ __ ] off
but my [ __ ] off is for [ __ ]
you know when people just when it's like
openly horseshit like come on
if someone said like you know like
[ __ ] psychics or something like that
you gotta meet my reader like get the
[ __ ] out of here
a reader i've had people say that to me
my psychic reader
let her read your cards i'm like no
terry cards
no i'm not gonna let her i'm not gonna
let her read my cards that reminds me of
miss cleo remember miss cleo
in the 1990s didn't dion warwick have a
show like psychic friends network wasn't
there something like that
was it dion warwick was it right yeah
dion worked the amazing singer
had the psychic friends network that's
so weird he was a singer and he did that
a woman dionne warwick do you know do
you know the way to san jose i know that
song yes yeah
psychic friends network 1992.
that's diony god yeah look at that
dion warwick would sit you down with a
bunch of people that were lying
and they would pretend that they knew
things and they would sit there oh
there's linda george oh my god
yeah that guy is psychic and she's
psychic and they're
uh oh these are people from uh uh one
life to live and date
another one so they're soap opera stars
that were like this psychic
changed the way i do my readings
now when i play my character who called
the psychic friends
the voices let me hear that give me some
of that it just ended up oh
go back that voice would be the end of
our relationship i mean it's just gonna
ultimately
destroy no no go back go back i need to
hear what this [ __ ] nonsense is
hear what one of our psychics had to say
about daytime tv's hottest couple
is this gonna be the end of our
relationship i mean is this going to
ultimately
destroy our i asked her who asked for
that yeah
meet others imagine that's the
commercial
she's like you asked her that what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you don't you know
we're going to be together forever
you're such an [ __ ] mark oh my god
how the [ __ ] did you ask the psychic
something you already know we're going
to be together forever
right god damn it
that uh first of all 90's infomercials
are glorious how about dion warwick's
hair
how about that that was something
special you never heard dionne warwick
sing
no i the song that you just sang i've
heard before but i didn't know who the
[ __ ] saying
i didn't know her name it's a beautiful
voice it's always sad when someone's
like genuinely talented and you want
you see them wind up like doing
something like that you're like oh yeah
people off
just stealing that is because it really
is the psychic within oh my god oh
boy what is that a game it's something
it's just like a kit
oh my god oh no do you remember
it's only 21.95 joe i feel like we
should order it
contains a full color video featuring
linda linda georgian that's that lady
go back to that so i could see what that
said there full color video featuring
lisa georgian linda georgian and the
master
psychics oh look they're taking in
two eyes how about they spell taking
wrong i don't trust them
they they're taking
they're taking you step by step but
they're spelling taking with an extra
eye nobody even caught that
i wonder if we'll go back to that in a
week and they'll go they're talking [ __ ]
about us
the psychic within do you remember
crossing over with john edward
oh that guy was a real charlatan all
right man you know i think he got fired
when he tried to do it with like 9 11
victims
i don't know if am i am i right about
that jamie i think that's what happened
but i'm going off memory on that one oh
my god yeah
the audacity oh i know that's what
happened the network was like you're
doing
what oh my god the audacity
oh that guy's terrible man that sounds
about correct
wow that was all memory too it makes
sense though i mean if you're a thief
you're a thief
yeah that's all they are they're just
thieves they're just doing it in a
different way
they're stealing and lying in a
different way it's just instead of like
breaking into someone's car
they're pretending that they have an
earpiece in and they're pretending they
they can sense where you know your
childhood trauma comes from
you lost your father in your attention
oh my god
some of these people it was less than
two months after it and
wow imagine that holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
imagine that he was like i know what
we're gonna do we're gonna capitalize on
this
this is gonna take our show to the next
level they uh
they caught one of these guys remember i
think the guy's name is peter popoff he
used to have all these infomercials at
night where he's like buy the holy water
and it'll save you
oh and then they caught him they i think
uh somebody
did this thing where it was like a sting
operation they had he had an earpiece in
and he was listening to people
and he was like telling them stuff that
they thought he couldn't know but he
heard it earlier
that's him look at that [ __ ] he looks
evil this [ __ ]
yeah he definitely looks gross whoa
wow he looks demonic he does doesn't he
like a ghost
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience